- What was your first
date like with your wife?
- It was more like a takeover, so.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love her already.
- Exactly.
That's what every woman says
that when I tell this story.
So my wife was, she basically told me that
this other guy was not her boyfriend.
So I asked her about it and she said,
"No he's not my type, he's not boyfriend,
"he's never been my boyfriend.
"You're my type."
- Oh, she went right in there.
- That was the first time
she ever said that to me.
And I was like okay.
So I think I called her the day after
and was like okay, so can
we go out on Tuesday night?
She's like no.
Okay.
- Oh just like no reason, just like nah.
- She's like no, I'm working.
I was like oh okay great.
I get it, how 'bout like Thursday?
No I'm working.
She was like this, I have Monday off.
That's the day we'll go out.
And I was like this, okay.
- Okay. (laughs)
- I didn't know what to say.
I was like ah okay.
- It's kinda hot.
She's bold.
- I think in hindsight.
- I think it worked.
- In hindsight, it worked.
In hindsight it worked.
I think in the moment I
was just kinda taken aback.
- Like, is she crazy?
Yeah.
- And I think I was drawn to that.
- That says more about you. (laughs)
- I was definitely drawn to that.
But yeah, and in the
first date, we actually,
we linked up during the
day, 'cause she was like,
I'm gonna work tonight
but let's do something during that day.
I was like, a day date, sexy.
Right.
One of the hottest things I've ever done.
Let me tell you right now.
So we went to this Vietnamese restaurant
We ate and then didn't want it to end.
So I was like what else could
I do, what else could I do?
And she was sitting
there and we were talking
and we were talking and she says to me,
can we get the first kiss out of the way?
She was like I'm feeling you,
and I'm telling you right now
if it's bad or if it's
whack, I just wanna go home
and never see you again.
(audience laughs)
We're still together!
So it was good!
- So good job!
- It was good!
I put it on her.
- Good job, good job.
So wait, my question though
is now she's your wife,
and after seven years this
is the thing I don't get
and I could never date an actor
because I ain't seeing my
man with some other chick up
on a film being like,
no it's just for work.
- It's just for work.
- That is a different
level of comfortable.
- First of all, I am an artist.
And it is acting.
- Sure.
- It is always 100% acting.
She just never got weird about it.
- She comfortable, she's confident.
- She's always said, 'cause
her girlfriends to this day,
even to this day will see
me make out with Cobie
on "Stumptown" and being like you know,
I don't know how you do it,
I don't know how you do it.
And she tells them the
same thing every time,
look he's never given me
a reason to doubt, so.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
That's cool.
That's a confident
relationship too, I love that.